one of my favorite places to just peruse
around on Google Maps is this little
rock called Gibraltar it's in Spain but
it's not in Spain it is technically the
United Kingdom like this is England
in Spain England held onto it because
this rock is right at this choke point
between Europe and Africa all the boats
have to go through this if they want to
go west and East because of that it got
the attention of Empires and a lot of
conflict over the years there's a bunch
of monkeys that live on this rock
which is its own wild story just some
things on the map you just look at and
you just feel
that they're different and they're
strange and there's a lot going on
and this is one of them